let's look a little bit at the market
for hamburgers so this is this is the
supply and the demand curve for the for
the price and the quantity of hamburgers
sold per day and so if we have a
completely unfettered market no
intervention no taxes nothing like that
then we see we have an equilibrium price
in an equilibrium quantity the
equilibrium price the equilibrium price
looks like it's about $3.75 per
hamburgers per hamburger the equilibrium
quantity looks like it's about a little
bit more to me if I draw that line a
little bit differently the equilibrium
quantity looks like it's about $3 or
sorry it's about three and a half
million hamburgers per day
and we just to review what we've talked
about before up here between between the
demand below the demand curve and above
the price above the use a price equals
$3 75 line right over here this is how
much value this is how much benefit the
consumers are getting above and beyond
what they have to pay so that is the
consumer surplus consumer surplus and
then between this price equals 375 line
and the supply curve you have your
producer surplus so this is how much
more the producers are getting for each
hamburger relative to what their
opportunity cost of producing that
incremental hamburger was so this right
over here is the producer surplus
producer surplus now let's say and
actually these numbers these numbers are
quasi realistic the I have a three and a
half million hamburgers per day I
actually looked it up before this video
looks like McDonald's at least based on
the information I got sold is a little
sells a little bit over four million
hamburgers per day in the United States
so I didn't clarify with just hamburgers
from one vendor or multiple vendors but
it's not a crazy number of hamburgers to
sell in a fairly large country but for
the sake of this it's not necessarily
McDonald's hamburgers we was talking
about this is the total market for
hamburgers in a country we're making the
kind of the simplifying assumption that
all hamburgers are created equal which
we know is not true now the government's
in this and this hypothetical
civilization says wow a lot of
hamburgers are being sold we need we
need to we we need more revenue for the
government to to do other things or
maybe to pay off their debt or whatever
they need to do and so they decide to
tax hamburgers they want to tax
hamburgers and they're going to make it
very simple and I'm gonna do a
percentage most sales taxes tend to be a
percentage of the price but instead
they're just gonna do a tax of one
dollar per hamburger one dollar per
hamburger per hamburger so let's think
about what this does to to to to the
surplus to the price at which
transactions will go on and what people
will have to pay versus what they will
have to get so at any given point at any
given point so if we look at the supply
curve right over here when we talked in
order to get someone to produce that
very first hamburger they have to get at
least two dollars for it because that's
their opportunity cost they could use
those exact same resources that land the
labor whatever else to produce something
else that has two dollars of value so
you have to pay them at least two
dollars in order for them to Bruce
hamburgers and the more hamburgers you
want the suppliers to produce you have
to pay them more and more for those
incremental hamburgers because they're
going to start using resources that
might have been better and better for
used for other things and that are not
as efficiently used for hamburgers you
have to pay them more and more and more
so this is what the the supply curve
that I originally drew right over in
magenta is what the suppliers need to
see in order to produce a certain
quantity if you want them to produce
three million hamburgers you have to
prop you have to get them you have to
pay be willing to pay three dollars per
hamburger because that's their
opportunity cost of those incremental
hamburgers up here now let's think about
what happens when you add the tax this
is what the suppliers are going to get
but or the producers are going to get
but when you put a tax the consumers are
gonna have to pay a dollar more so it
over here in order to produce this much
the suppliers are going to have to get
are going to have to get three dollars
per hamburger but then the consumers are
gonna have to pay a dollar more so
they're going to have to pay one dollar
more in order to get the suppliers to
produce two million hamburgers you're
gonna have to pay them this much you're
gonna have to pay them about 250 but
then the consumers are gonna have to pay
a dollar more than that so they're gonna
have to pay that much in order to get
them to produce at all you're gonna have
to pay at least two dollars but then if
the supplier
the producers are getting $2 the
consumers are gonna have to pay $1 more
for the tax so they have to pay $1 more
so one way to think about it is the
supply curve from the consumers point of
view is going to be shifted $1 more than
the supply curve from the producers
point of view so it's going to be
shifted up $1 so it's going to be look
it's gonna look something I could do a
better job than that it's gonna look
something it's going to look something
like that
where at every point because this is a
fixed dollar it's not a percentage at
every point this distance right over
here is going to be is going to be $1 so
what happens there from the consumers
point of view from the consumers point
of view what we have is now a new price
that they're willing to consume at
because now there's this this this
reality is not possible anymore this
reality there's no way for the consumers
to pay 350 and for the producers to see
350 as well and so we get to a new a new
I guess equilibrium price and
equilibrium quantity now because now
since this is from the consumers point
of view the point in which they
intersect is right over there which is
about it's a little bit over $4 per
burger and it's a slightly lower
quantity it's about let's just say just
for round numbers that's about 3 million
burgers per day so what happened what
happened there well before this whole
area was a total surplus below this
Green Line was the producer surplus
above the Green Line and below this
curve right here was a consumer surplus
now we've lost part of it we've lost
we've lost this part right over here so
this is our deadweight loss this is no
longer part of the total consumer and
producer surplus
so that is deadweight loss so the the
taxation got us from a an efficient
situation where we had that kind of
maximum consumer and producer surplus
deadweight this is our dead weight loss
over here and how much revenue is the
government going to get now well if we
assume that this is 3 million they're
gonna have 3 million burgers they're
gonna have 3 million burgers so this is
3 million right over here they're gonna
have 3 million burgers x times $1 per
burger so let me do it this way so this
is
so this length right over here it's
going to be the area of this rectangle
that I'm doing an orange so this length
right over here is 3 that length right
over there's 3 million and then the
height is that dollar the height is the
dollar so let me shade it in the height
is that dollar right over there
so this is going to be one dollar height
so the tax revenue that the government
is going to get is three million times
one dollar three million burgers times
$1 which is going to be three million
dollars per day three million dollars
per day which is interesting because
maybe the government official thought
they were going to get more because they
look at the progression projections they
said wait there's going to be three and
a half million burgers sold per day so
I'm going to get three and a half
million dollars but they didn't realize
is that they're making the burgers more
expensive so there's going to be a lower
quantity there's going to be a lower
quantity demanded actual the actual
clearing quantity or the actual
equilibrium quantity now is only going
to be three million and the way we see
it removed this surplus here from both
the consumer surplus and and the
producer surplus and and no one's
getting that not even the the
government's getting that so no one's
getting that white part right over there
and this orange part right over here is
eating into the consumer surplus so now
they are paying more they're paying more
than their or another way to think about
it is the difference between the benefit
they're getting the benefit and they're
getting and what they're paying at any
given point for any given incremental
consumer is now less and the producer
surplus is less the the excess of what
they're getting for each hamburger
versus their opportunity cost is now
less so the producer surplus has now
been shrunken back to this area right
over here and these are curves here so
we can't just do simple geometry to
figure out the area of triangles you
would actually have to do a little
calculus to figure out the area of these
curves and then the consumer surplus has
been pushed back to this area above the
orange right over here
so you see government's for the most
part have to do some type of Taxation in
order to get a revenue and it could be
income tax or it could be a sales tax
like this right over here but when they
do it it gets us into a non efficient
state and it does it does cause some
depending on the how these curves are
Shay
it does cause some deadweight loss some
benefit in excess of what had to be paid
some of that disappears but it allows at
least the government to get revenue
depending on whether you think that's a
good thing or not